missing kayaker was rescued after  surviving several days adrift in  Everglades Everglades National Park so  check out this dramatic video Florida  sheriff's deputies rushed to pull mark  meal from his kayak yesterday the 67  year old hunt embarked on a solo  kayaking trip On January 22nd he was due  back seven days later but never returned  authorities were able to track him down  after downloading data from his phone  they washed ashore  Sunday night along with some of his  other belongings this is amazing I mean  I think you two grew up in South Florida  I don't think I could survive in my  backyard for that amount of time let  alone Everglades National Park the  authorities say just a few more hours  life or death in deciduous there's lots  of Gators lots of Gators mosquitoes as  you pointed out it look good when it's  tough washed up over the weekend but as  it turns out everything that's good at  anything as you  you